[موسيقى] أجنبية،
لذا على الأرجح حظيت برحلة جيدة ليست
مثل رحلة السيد حازم، لقد كانت رحلة مثيرة للاهتمام حقًا،
لذا أولاً وقبل كل شيء سأقدم
تعريفًا عن نفسي، لدي
درجة البكالوريوس في الهندسة النووية،
لذا على الأرجح أقضي حياتي في
المفاعلات النووية  محاكاة الطاقة ثم
بدأت العمل لدى شركات أمريكية
تسمى veter Corp وهنا
بدأت رحلتي لدخول
سوق الثورة الصناعية الرابعة الجديدة
ومعرفة المزيد عن الذكاء الاصطناعي وعلوم البيانات
في مجال الطاقة ومجال المرافق
فتعلمت ذلك الوقت  كان الأمر صعبًا حقًا،
لم تكن هناك موارد، لم تكن هناك
موارد كافية للتعلم، لذلك بدأت في
قراءة الكتب ولكن مع مرور الوقت كنت أبحث
وأسعى إلى
عملية أسرع للتعلم من
الإنترنت، لذا نصحني أحد الأشخاص
بأخذ دورات عبر الإنترنت في
العلوم المتحدة  كان الأمر صعبًا بعض الشيء أيضًا
لأنها كانت تجربتي الأولى في
ذلك ثم بدأت في اكتشاف الدورات التدريبية عبر الإنترنت
فأخذت أكثر من 180 دورة عبر الإنترنت
والذكاء الاصطناعي وعلوم البيانات بين
عامي 2014 و 2016. ثم سأبدأ بتدريس
علم البيانات والعين  وكوني
مستشارًا للعديد من الشركات في
المنطقة مثل شركة Beyond
Limits وشركة Vetta Corp وAramco والمملكة العربية السعودية
SDC، هناك العديد من البنوك في المنطقة،
ثم أردت أن أبدأ شركتي
الناشئة
لذلك اعتقد الجميع أنني سأبدأ
الذكاء الاصطناعي  لقد
أخبرتهم أن هناك مشكلة أكبر
نحتاج إلى حلها هنا في
البلدان العربية، وهي عملية التعلم السريعة،
طلابنا، الجيل القادم،
يحتاجون إلى مكتبة ضخمة أو مركز معرفة
لتكنولوجيا علوم الثورة الصناعية الرابعة التي  سد الفجوة
بين مخرجات الجامعة
ومتطلبات السوق لأنه في البداية
في هذه الثورة، كان معدل النمو
تجريبيًا جدًا ومرتفعًا جدًا بحيث لا يستطيع أحد مواكبة
التعلم الآلي للذكاء الاصطناعي،
سيكون blockchain metaverse ثلاثة كل يوم، هناك
تقنية جديدة كل يوم
هناك  خوارزمية جديدة لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى
منصة لا مركزية لسد
الفجوة بين
الباحثين عن المعرفة ومعرفة السائقين
هنا حيث بدأت الجامعة لديها أول
منصة لامركزية لتعلم الأشعة تحت الحمراء في
المنطقة المصغرة لذلك كان لدي رؤية
لإنشاء أكبر منصة رقمية  جامعة عبر الإنترنت
في العالم العربي،
والآن الحمد لله، بعد ثلاث
سنوات من التشغيل، لدينا نصف مليون
طالب من جميع أنحاء
الدول العربية، نحن أكبر منصة للتعليم الإلكتروني
في المنطقة المصغرة لدينا أكثر
من 1200 دورة عبر الإنترنت
باللغة العربية، لذلك لدينا  كان التركيز على إثراء
اللغة العربية على الإنترنت لذا
عد إلى موضوعنا ما هو المستقبل
لذلك كنت أفكر في ما يجب أن أقدمه
في تايدكس يجب أن يكون شيئًا فريدًا من نوعه،
فكر في المستقبل وليس
الآن
لذلك أردت أن أفعل شيئًا بشأن الدردشة
gbt  حول Chevy GT موجودة الآن، لذا
أريد أن أخبركم بأشياء
ستحدث في المستقبل، ربما قد تكون
صحيحة، وربما تكون خاطئة، ولكن
هناك الكثير من الأبحاث، وهناك الكثير من
الروايات التي لا يتفقون معها أو يتفقون مع
رؤية المستقبل، لذا  على الأرجح
لدينا
أربع ثورات صناعية
والآن نعيش الثورة الرابعة
والتوزيع مع ثورة البيانات الضخمة
الموضوع الرئيسي لتوزيع
البيانات وأصبح بعد هذه
الثورة الكثير من التكنولوجيا والعلوم
مثل الذكاء الاصطناعي والتعلم الآلي و
blockchain 3D  طباعة الحوسبة السحابية
كلها مرتبطة بالثورة الرابعة
وبالتالي هناك
الكثير من الشركات والشاحنات الكبيرة والصناعية الكبيرة
التي تتحدث عن metaverse لذا على
الأرجح ما هو metaverse
ولماذا يجب أن نفكر بعمق في
MidFirst لماذا من المهم حقًا أن
فكر كيف سيكون المستقبل،
كيف سنعيش
من هنا إلى 90 عامًا، لذلك على الأرجح في
Metaverse يمكننا القراءة والكتابة والامتلاك،
لذلك إذا كنت تريد فهم المستقبل،
فنحن بحاجة إلى العودة إلى التاريخ
من المحتمل أننا مررنا بالكثير من
التكنولوجيا والثورات في هذه
الصناعة وخاصة
صناعة الإنترنت، فقد بدأنا بالويب وان ويب 2
ويب 3 ويمكننا أن نذكر أكبر
المنصات في كل ويب،
لذا
وفقًا لهذا أه ويب بي 3، لذلك على
الأرجح ويب 3  هو الآن الموضوع الرئيسي الذي
يتحدث عنه الجميع، فما علاقة web3
بالواقع الافتراضي لتكنولوجيا blockchain AI، السيد XR، لذلك على الأرجح فإن
الاختلافات الرئيسية بين web 1 وweb 2
web 3 هي التفاعل، لذلك في web 1
لا أعرف مثلك  هم مثل هذا
الجيل، الجيل القديم الذي اعتادوا
التفاعل مع نقطة عمل لم نتمكن من
قراءتها إلا من الهاتف المحمول، لا يوجد
تفاعل مثل الويب 2 حيث يمكننا القراءة،
يمكننا كتابة التعليقات، يمكننا التواصل،
يمكننا الاتصال،
والآن في الفيلم 3 يمكننا القراءة و  اكتب
وامتلك، لذلك أعتقد أن الجميع على دراية
بتكنولوجيا blockchain و
nft ومفهوم العملة المشفرة الذي
بدأ في عام 2008. لذلك على الأرجح أن
مفهوم الملكية
سيغير المفهوم بأكمله فوق
تقنية الويب B3 والواقع الافتراضي،
فما هو  متوسط، لذا حظًا سعيدًا للغاية في الويب
واحد، فقد اعتدنا على التعامل مع
النص الثابت في الويب 2 مع
النص التفاعلي مثل Facebook وInstagram وTwitter،
والعديد من المنصات التي نقوم
بها الآن تشبه تقنية الويب 2، web3 عبارة عن
اقتصاديات افتراضية إنها بالكامل
عالم مختلف، لذلك ربما مثل الكثير منكم
الذين يدرسون نظريات أينشتاين
حول مفهوم الكلمات المتعددة، وكيف
سنعيش في حروب متعددة في نفس الوقت،
جسديًا أو عقليًا، لذلك ربما تكون
التكنولوجيا هي الطريقة لجعل
كل شيء صحيحًا
لذلك، نظرًا
لأن شبكة الويب الخاصة بالمؤسسة تمت استضافتها
والتحكم فيها من قبل الشركات التي لديها
نظامين أساسيين وهي تعمل، لذلك
لم يعد هناك المزيد من المركزية بشكل عام، فسوف
يصبح كل شيء لامركزيًا
وفقًا للبنية التحتية التي نريدها
لأجهزة الكمبيوتر الشخصية الخاصة بها، لقد كانت
ويب لامركزية 2، وكانت
السحابة غائمة  الهاتف المحمول الآن ومع B3 هي
النهاية الخلفية ولكني أوافق تمامًا على أن FS
ستكون عبارة عن شبكات blockchain،
لذا فإن التحكم في التحكم في الويب
عندما كانت شبكة محلية لا مركزية
لم يكن هناك اتصال عالمي أو
مركزي مثل السحابة التي لدينا
الآن  في web3، نعود إلى
المركزية ولكن
بمفهوم مختلف تمامًا مع
مفهوم blockchain، سيكون أكثر قوة
وأسرع وأكثر أمانًا،
لذلك دعونا نتحدث أكثر عن
مفهوم metaverse، لذا فإن الطور الاستوائي عبارة عن شبكة من
عالم افتراضي ثلاثي الأبعاد  فهي متصلة
بتمكين الأشخاص من التفاعل مع
بعضهم البعض في الوقت الفعلي بغض النظر عن
مكان تواجدهم فعليًا،
لذلك نتذكر نظرية
سفر أينشتاين عبر الزمن، لذلك يمكننا الآن
السفر عبر الزمن ليس جسديًا ولكن
عقليًا يمكننا السفر عبر الزمن، فكيف
نرى المستقبل سيكون الفتيل عبارة عن
حرب متعددة هذه الحرب ليست كافية
بالنسبة لنا فنحن نفتقر إلى الموارد
ويتزايد عدد السكان بمرور الوقت لذا
نحتاج إلى الانتقال إلى كلمات أخرى عقليًا وليس
جسديًا باستخدام
تقنية metaverse لذا  على الأغلب ميتا هي
كلمة يونانية تسمى ما وراء معنى
الأمتار ما وراء الكون مقابل ما وراء
الكون لذلك أعتقد أننا
نعيش في المستقبل الآن من خلال
رفع تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي و
blockchain والويب B3 على ما أعتقد
الروايات  نستخدمها للقراءة وأه الأفلام التي
نستخدمها لمشاهدتها أصبحت حقيقة بطريقة ما لأن
الذكاء الاصطناعي كان
فيلمًا وكانت
خوارزميات قديمة تسمى
التعلم الآلي من عام 1950
وأقدم بكثير ولكن من حول الذكاء الاصطناعي إلى
روايات ريالتي والتكنولوجيا بالطبع على
الأرجح  بدأت أؤمن بأن كل
ما نقرأه ونشاهده
أصبح حقيقيًا وحقيقة يجب التعايش معها،
لذا فإن
المرة الأولى التي تم فيها
ذكر Metaverse عن رواية تسمى Snow
Crash أوصي الجميع بقراءة هذه
الرواية وهذه الرواية بها بعض المفهوم
والعامل  لذا فإن metaverse
ثلاثي الأبعاد، لذا فهو مساحة ثلاثية الأبعاد
مثل عالمنا، كناية عن
العالم الحقيقي، لذا ستكون نسخة مبنية على
العالم الحقيقي، ربما لا تكون كذلك، لذا ربما
يمكننا أن نعيش عالمًا خياليًا،
حروبًا مختلفة من الميتا  versicos
الآن لدينا نظام لامركزي، لدينا
Atlas Ward، لدينا كلمة metaverse مختلفة
في الإصدار التجريبي، لذلك نحن
نتحدث عن تقنية كثيرة في الإصدار التعريفي،
blockchain لا يزال في
الإصدار التجريبي وأعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى المزيد من 10
إلى 20 عامًا  للحصول على هذه التكنولوجيا،
يمكن للمستخدمين الناضجين الوصول إلى metaverse باستخدام
معدات الواقع الافتراضي في الوقت الحالي،
أعتقد أنك ستنتقل إلى
تقنية مختلفة بمرور الوقت والتي يمكن أن تكون
أكثر مرونة وأرخص بكثير، حيث
يتم تجربة metaverse
من منظور الشخص الأول في الوقت
الحالي  هي التكنولوجيا ما زلنا
نبحث عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي الفائق ليأخذ مكانًا ويبدأ في
التعامل مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
بطريقة مختلفة تمامًا، حيث يمكن تخصيص الصور الرمزية
وتخصيصها وهنا يمكننا التحدث عن
التوأم الرقمي لذا فهو جزء من
تقنية metaverse و  لقد تم
دمج الذكاء الاصطناعي على الأرجح، يجمع
Meta مقابل بين
تكنولوجيا مختلفة والواجهة الأمامية التي يمكننا التحدث بها
معك حول الواقع المختلط الافتراضي XR
أعتقد أن معظمكم ممن جربوا الواقع الافتراضي
والواقع من قبل
والبرمجيات الوسيطة ستكون عملية التكامل
Node.js أو web B3
في الوقت الحالي باستخدام تقنية Misforms أو
Node.js 3dgs والواجهة الخلفية، نحن
نتعامل مع تقنيات إجمالية مختلفة
مثل blockchain
كشبكة والذكاء الاصطناعي كمفهوم، لذلك على
الأرجح ما هو دور  الذكاء الاصطناعي في
Metaverse،
لذلك سأتحدث عن المزيد حول
تكنولوجيا الواجهة الأمامية،
لذا يتوقع العلماء أن
المستقبل سيكون حول الرمش،
لذا ترمش وتتصل بالإنترنت، ولا حاجة للواقع
الافتراضي، لذا فهم ينفقون
الكثير  بحث حول إنشاء بعض الأماكن
التي تتصل بها بالعالم عبر الإنترنت
خاصة في عالم Metaverse حيث
يمكنك الاتصال بالإنترنت من خلال اللعب فقط وأنا
أؤمن بهذا نعم أنا أؤمن بهذا،
ربما يأتي هذا بعد 10 إلى 15
عامًا، فهناك العديد من الشركات الكبرى
تعمل الشاحنات الكبيرة في العالم على
استثمار كل هذا لتطوير الممرات التي
تنقلك عبر الإنترنت بمجرد الرمش
حتى تتمكن من التحقق من حسابك على
Facebook بمجرد الرمش أو يمكنك
الانتقال من metaverse إلى
metaverse آخر عن طريق الرمش وربما يمكنك أن
تكون موجودًا  في تحول آخر من خلال وجود
شخصية ذكاء اصطناعي مخصصة
تختار ديون وهو يلعب الشطرنج بجانب
الملعب،
لذلك سأقدم نبذة عن
تقنية blockchain، ربما لا أحد على علم
بتكنولوجيا blockchain،
تزدهر blockchain الآن كتقنية وليس
كعملة مشفرة، لذا فإن العملة المشفرة هي
تطبيق لـ blockchain ولكن
blockchain في حد ذاته عبارة عن
تقنية مستقلة تعمل على تغيير العالم
من سوط 2 إلى webv3 كواجهة خلفية لذا فإن
الميزات الرئيسية في Affliction هي
الأمان واللامركزية وربما يكون من
الصعب حقًا اختراق هذا النظام ليس
مثل النظام المركزي  السحب في الوقت الحالي، لذلك لا
تزال blockchain في الإصدار الأفضل،
وأعتقد أن العقود الآجلة لـ blockchain
ستكون عبارة عن كتلة متصلة، لذا فإن
عنق الكتلة يولد
كتل مختلفة من نفس الكتلة،
سيكون تحويل المعلومات
والبيانات من خلال الكتل أسرع
سيكون أسرع بكثير لأن لدينا 5G
في الوقت الحالي ونحتاج إلى تطوير المزيد من
تقنيات البرامج مثل blockchain
إلى مرحلة أخرى من
الإصدار التجريبي إلى الإصدار Alpha لنحصل على
التطبيقات الرئيسية
على blockchain في الوقت الحالي مثل شبكة البلوك.  nft
ومنصة Bitcoin ethereum يقومون
بعمل الشبكة الصيفية والعقد الذكي،
لذلك دعونا نتحدث عن ثورة الذكاء الاصطناعي أو
التطور، لذلك
هناك مرحلتان رئيسيتان وثلاث مراحل
للذكاء الاصطناعي، الذكاء العصبي الاصطناعي، الذكاء
العام الاصطناعي،
والذكاء الاصطناعي الفائق كما
نرى من خلال  في الوقت الذي نرى فيه قدرات
خوارزميات الذكاء الاصطناعي تصبح أكثر عمقًا،
لدينا الآن إمكانية الشحن ولدينا
عدسة ولدينا الكثير من الخوارزميات
التي يمكن أن تكون إبداعية ومبتكرة،
لذا أعتقد على الأرجح أننا ندخل
عالم الذكاء العام الاصطناعي وهذا ما سيحدث
ربما إلى 25 إلى 75 عامًا من هنا، لذلك
أعتقد أن هذا الكبد الذي نتحدث عنه
وخوارزمية الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يصل إلى
الذكاء البشري من
منظور مناطق مختلفة أنا ضد هذا ولكن
هذا ما يتحدث عنه المستقبل.
لن أتحدث عن الاختراق الفائق للذكاء الاصطناعي،
فهناك كتاب يسمى
الذكاء الاصطناعي الفائق وأه هناك
الكثير من علامات الاستفهام في تلك الحقبة لأنها
لا تزال فلسفة وما زالت
تتمحور حول تقدير مجتمعات الذكاء الاصطناعي
في المستقبل.
أعتقد أن الأمر سيكون مخيفًا إلى حد ما في
المستقبل ولكن دعونا نبقى في
الذكاء الاصطناعي العام لأنه واعد، فأنا أحب
هذا المجال أكثر من الذكاء الاصطناعي الفائق،
لذلك سنرى الكثير في
السنوات القادمة من الذكاء العام
للذكاء الاصطناعي وخاصة في metaverse
لذا، في مفهوم metaverse باعتباره ذكاءً اصطناعيًا،
يمكنني تخصيص تدريب
الخوارزمية بدقة لمعرفة المزيد عني حتى أتمكن من
العيش في أكوان
متعددة مختلفة، ويمكنني العيش في أطلس وعالم
لامركزي ومختلف
تم إنشاؤه في نفس الوقت، لذا قد
ألعب الشطرنج  مع صديقي في أطلس
وإبرام صفقة مع صديقي مع
عميل آخر ربما في اللامركزية
ووجودي هنا فعليًا لتعليمك
عن الذكاء الاصطناعي، لذلك هذا هو المستقبل كيف
يمكننا أن نكون في أماكن مختلفة في
نفس الوقت وكيف يمكننا السفر عبر الزمن  إن
استخدام تقنية الذكاء الاصطناعي في العالم الخارجي، لذا فإن
الربط بين الفلسفة والتكنولوجيا
هو الطريقة لتكون مبتكرًا
ومبدعًا في المستقبل، لذلك
كل ما لدينا الآن
اعتقدنا أنه سيكون أمرًا غاضبًا ولكنه
أصبح حقيقيًا بمرور الوقت وهذا
يعطي  نحن نستمع دائمًا ونؤمن بأن ما
كان هناك من
يقرأ الروايات والكتب
سيصبح حقيقة، لذا هنا مثل الطاولة
تتحدث عن ظهور Ruby 3 و
5G، لذا فإن مزيج النمو بين
التكنولوجيا ضخم جدًا، ولهذا السبب
عندما بدأت شركة ناشئة، فكرت في
أننا بحاجة إلى منصة للحصول على كل
تكنولوجيا المحتوى هذه باللغة العربية لأننا
نستحق ذلك، نستحق أن نكون على دراية
بالتكنولوجيا في الوقت الحالي، خاصة في
الوقت الحالي، لن يكون كافيًا أن
تكون مهندسًا في الذكاء الاصطناعي، بل  لن تكون
معرفة المخاطر غير المحدودة كافية، فأنت
بحاجة إلى معرفة كل شيء وكل ما
تحتاجه، عملية تعلم سريعة،
تحتاج إلى مكتبة ضخمة
من الدورات التدريبية عبر الإنترنت المحدثة حيث
يمكنك التعلم واكتساب المعرفة ومشاركتها
لأنك
الآن  طالب ولكن غدًا
ستكون مدرسًا، لذا فإن كونك مدرسًا
ليس بالأمر السهل، لذا ستكون
سائق المعرفة وسيكون هناك
الكثير من الباحثين عن المنطق، لذلك نحن
نعتبر أنفسنا أوبر
المعرفة حيث المعرفة
شركات بناء البنية التحتية للذكاء الاصطناعي
هناك الكثير من المنافسة وهناك
الكثير ممن يبنون شركات الرجال ولكننا
نركز على
البنية التحتية المناسبة للجيل الجديد،
الجيل القادم هو المعرفة، لذا فإن
المعرفة هي القوة والقوة هي المال، لذلك على
الأرجح هذا هو السبب في
أنني  لقد ذكرت للتو الكثير من التكنولوجيا في
العرض التقديمي الخاص بي حول إلى أين
يتجه المستقبل وربما كطلاب جامعيين،
البعض منكم يدرس
علوم الكمبيوتر والبعض يدرس
علوم البيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي والرحلة الحقيقية
تبدأ بعد الجامعة، يبدو الأمر كما لو أنني
أوصيكم جميعًا  للبدء في أخذ
دورة عبر الإنترنت وتطوير
عملية التعلم الذاتي لأن التعلم الذاتي
يشبه الماس على الأرجح، فهو الطريقة التي
يمكنك من خلالها النمو، ويمكنك المنافسة في
السوق، ويمكنك قراءة المستقبل
بشكل أفضل من أي شخص آخر،
لذلك على الأرجح سيكون هذا
نهاية العرض التقديمي كان
عرضًا سريعًا وآمل أن ينال إعجاب الجميع ولكم
جزيل الشكر
[تصفيق]